You know,
I'm not sure I've ever seen anyone so spectacularly miss the point.
You think I get dressed and do my makeup for other people?
The point is to get dressed and present yourself the way that you feel
beautiful. Which does not mean that you're gonna wear pajamas
and not wanna get dressed up.
It just means you're not looking for other people's approval
and how you do.
So I dress the way I do
and I put on makeup because I like looking at myself,
looking cute. It makes me feel confident.
It feels like a physical expression of my internal self.
Women can still wear makeup and do it for themselves.
Misogyny in this take is remarkably obduce.